jazz was born in a little flop house in
new orleans and it's just because people
were
crammed in there they spoke five
different languages they couldn't talk
to each other the only way they could
communicate
was with jazz that's just not true the
people who started jazz i mean we don't
know who that person is
but they're definitely all
african-american they all could speak
english
it didn't start off like like that
what's up gq
this is robert glasper musician producer
and this is the breakdown
[Music]
first up bird bird
was charlie parker's nickname saxophone
player charlie parker
they called him bird everybody back then
had nicknames back in the 40s and 40s
all the jazz positions i'm not sure how
a lot of them got their nicknames but
you just called a net
and you're like why did i just call you
burger everybody calls you that so i'm
gonna tell you that
the portrayal of how everything looks is
spot on where the musicians are standing
all that kind of stuff spot on
a lot of times in movies they don't have
a person that really knows jazz or what
a jam session looks like
they have people staying in the wrong
place and the sound is good you can tell
that those are actual jazz musicians
playing
just by the way they're holding their
horn and when they play there's certain
movements that
jazz musicians do even when the
saxophone player is blowing
and how he's moving with different lines
certain lines are going up last
saxophone player when they play
notes that go up they go up and when
they play notes they go down they kind
of do that it's a movement body movement
thing like
and the same thing for the bass and the
drums if you're hearing a symbol you
should be seeing him play assembled
so they have all that pretty good for
the for the most part
it's good
[Music]
this particular scene takes place in
1939
so the actual style of music they're
playing
fits the time period they're playing
bebop it's just the language like we all
have a language there's spanish there's
japanese there's
english bebop is an actual language it's
basically how to get from one note to
another note
through other notes so it's based like a
maze of notes to get to another note
it's like uh
so charlie parker he's known as the the
father of bebop
bebop was there before he got there but
not
at the level once he influenced it it
just went to a whole different level
in this movie people are already playing
charlie parker language while charlie
parker's a kid
that's a little bit off but in real life
there are things that charlie parker
influenced
as an adult the stuff that those guys
are playing up there the saxophone
players when they're going back and
forth
that's stuff that charlie parker
actually influenced a lot so
you know he influenced the music so much
that it it broadened it so much to where
all these other genres would pop off in
there charlie parker spawned people like
john coltrane and john coltrane really
influenced the free jazz movement
you know and it just goes on and on like
a tree it grows
on stage you can see two saxophone
players playing at each other
like one place another place they kind
of go back and forth we call that
battling
they have that in hip-hop they call it
rap battling they have it in
different genres where you kind of just
go back and forth and try to cut the
other person cutting me like
you're trying to be better than that
person trade force forces a certain
amount of measures
it's like a conversation it's kind of
like sharpening up the swords one sword
sharpens the other swords the saxophone
pretty much has become kind of like the
face of jazz anything you see that's
like
we need something jazzy most of the time
they're going to get a saxophone player
because that represents emotion
and represents like romance i think
really because of charlie parker
specifically
the genre is kind of represented by the
saxophone because charlie parker is such
a huge influence
on the genre itself what's your name
who to play with little forest whitaker
his
look and everything his mannerism how he
walked up and everything is
spot on he kind of walked on stage
without having the conversation of what
he's going to play
normally in real life you're a new guy
you're young they'll ask you
what do you want to play but some people
are just hard on you and you walk up
they're like okay young buck
what you got boom and you better know
the tune if you don't know the tune you
have to act like you know the tune
or kind of figure it out from the very
beginning you see he's already sweating
he's nervous and that's a real thing
when you first go up and you try to play
with older guys people that's been
around
obviously it looks like it's hot in that
club anyway but he is really sweating
because that's
nerves like when i would go jam sessions
you have to write your name
on the little tablet and then they call
you up to play so i'd be so nervous
before i went on stage
now he's just trying to find it he
doesn't know what what to do he's kind
of just trying to
find his way and you can slowly see all
the jazz musicians on the stage looking
like
what is this fool doing what's happening
knowing what you're going to play when
you go to the jam session is
is the scary part of going to a jam
session because
most of those people in there have been
playing for a very long time
so they know a lot of tunes and in the
jazz
book there's so many tunes to learn
playing was bad because there was no
rhythmic component to it it was just
kind of like
the notes look like my eyes like
that's what it sounded like if notes had
eyes that's what it would look like but
you can tell he can actually play but
the nerves have gotten
the best of him because he's not locked
in rhythmically at all with the drummer
at all he's going on his own pulse at
that point just his confidence and
his movements and everything it's kind
of just like he's playing
by himself alone and
the other cats can tell that they can
tell the note choices
weren't making any sense just playing
wrong notes here and there technically
there are no wrong notes in jazz
but there's wrong in jazz they say
there's no wrong notes because
it's expression it's like there's no
wrong colors in painting because it's
art you can't go wrong in art but
there's a difference between playing a
wrong note
on purpose and playing a wrong note
because you didn't know the right
those are two different things they
sound different they feel different
it's a real story the drummer uh i
believe it might have been joe jones
that did that to a young charlie parker
when parker went up to play
and that's kind of a thing you do when
the person that's playing
is in dealing they say you ain't dealing
and that means like
you're not really playing well you're
not hanging with the level that's there
that's happened people stop playing
behind you
you're playing and you're not dealing
right you'll turn around you'll hear
literally the instruments dropping out
one by one and you'll realize yo i'm
playing by myself
he wasn't trying to like sever his head
off or anything like that he'd do it
kind of by his feet to let him know hey
i'm throwing this
towards you because you're doing
something wrong when you get embarrassed
on stage
those those situations never leave you
you remember those for the rest of your
life
and a lot of times it can make you
better you never want that to happen
again
so you go home and you practice and you
hope to go back and be better than you
were
something that people can be like okay
he can play you can play next up
la la land
the jazz band playing on here it's south
i'm not sure what the song is but it
sounds like they're playing something
from the 50s or the 60s
particularly that piano line the piano
plays playing
[Music]
that's a very typical kind of sound
jazz in the 50s and 60s maybe in that
era they sound good there's nothing like
crazy about it it sounds like something
you would hear at a jazz club while
you're talking having a drink having a
small something like that very cool
casual straightforward kind of just
tuned
the setting's good for that the musical
setting is good for that jazz was born
in a little
flop house in new orleans and it's just
because people were crammed in there
they spoke five different languages they
couldn't talk to each other the only way
they could communicate
was with jazz that's just not true
that part is not true the people who
started jazz i mean we don't know who
that person
is but they're definitely all
african-american they all could speak
english
for sure it didn't start off like like
that
i can definitely tell you that people
dispute exactly how
jazz came about the very beginnings of
jazz a lot of people say it did start in
new orleans
and then there are some people say it
started in kansas we don't really know
exactly but definitely wasn't like that
for sure
what about kenny g i mean what about
elevator music
you know jazz music that i know what
about it
people who don't listen to jazz tend to
think that jazz sounds like elevator
music
and there's some validity to that the
elevator music that you're hearing
they picked that particular music
because it's good for the elevator it's
just something that's kind of
cool kind of boring because it's
elevated you want to startle people when
you want to elevate
like jazz is like you know known more
for being instrumental music
than it is even having singers just the
fact that it's just instruments
kind of makes people feel like oh well
we can put that on
and people can talk and do whatever
they're doing and it's not going to be
too much going on i mean if you took a
poll and you asked the
average person what's jazz or whatever
it is i think most people would think
like
kenny g is is jazz
you don't really get to hear much bebop
in the world there's there's so many
styles of jazz honestly a smooth jazz
electronic jazz straight ahead jab this
is a part of the genre it doesn't
represent the whole genre
and i love kimchi i had i had a
silhouette album when i was in
seventh grade it's all relevant you know
you just gotta kind of know
what you're listening sometimes where i
grew up
there was this station called kjaz 103
and people would just put on
that station when they had a cocktail
party and everyone will kind of just
talk over it
so this is a real conversation people
have she's younger
and she's saying what about the jazz
that i know and he's more of a history
buff and he's an actual jazz position
so he knows the history of it the
younger you are
that's that's what you know about a
specific genre same thing with hip-hop
same thing with r b
and then you have people who are older
who say oh well no
this is not the real thing real things
back here so that's always
been a clash with people and and music
for sure just understanding that you
know music changes
you have to just step back and let it do
that and acknowledge it
so for certain jazz performances you
kind of go
in knowing what you're getting into
sometimes you are the focal point and
then there are those times where you
play
and you know your background music but
in this particular instance
it looks like they're just like you know
at a jazz club at a bar
and that's just the band that's playing
he's able to talk and hang out and do
that kind of thing
it's okay cause most jazz musicians know
what the vibe is when they get to the
venue
every one of these guys is composing the
rearranging they're writing
and they're playing the melody they're
just and now look the trumpet
he's got his own idea and so it's
conflict
and it's compromise so what he's saying
right here is very very very true
about when you watch a jazz band you're
seeing what's happening in real time
there's composition happenings people
are writing stuff on the spot
so you play a melody you play the song
and then everybody takes a solo
and the solo is just your expression of
that song
what you're feeling in that moment and
you're watching everybody
play in that moment it's like literally
art in real life
it's happening right in front of you
when you go see a jazz band and you see
how it works so you can see
sometimes the clone of the conflict
between
the musicians and working their way out
of a problem or something like that so
it's very very much
uh something to see versus just
something to hear
[Applause]
and it's dying it's time
it's dying that's a real thing people
say like jazz is dying or jazz is dead
and i don't agree the tradition of jazz
is that it changes
that it always changes every 10 years it
goes through a change that's actually
the real tradition so when people
purists say
what you're doing is in jazz or jazz is
dead because it doesn't sound like it
used to
they're not really purists if you're
really purist and you really love jazz
you know that it changes ask any jazz
periods who their favorite
jazz musician is probably the one that
gets the most votes is probably miles
davis and miles davis
kept changing the music he changed the
music like seven times when he died he
was
on the brink of doing hip-hop music i
always wanted to be relevant
i always wanted to do music of now and i
always wanted to
bring jazz into the next thing always so
that's
literally what the history of the music
is and i think that
we're honoring our forefathers of the
music by taking what they did
and changing it and making something new
that's what it's supposed to be
what are you gonna do i'm gonna have my
own club
really yes we're gonna play whatever we
want
whenever we want however we want as long
as it's pure
jazz jazz purists i mean the term really
is they just choose an
era of jazz that they really connect
with
and they want it to stay like that and
that makes it pure pretty much
anything before the 70s once the 70s
came into play
then you got people including electronic
instruments you know
electric keyboards electric bass and
things of that nature which
change the style of music change the
sound in a lot of people's mind
that's not jazz anymore jazz is this
everything's acoustic
upright bass piano acoustic drums
some horns so that's kind of what their
their thing is it has to stay like that
if it doesn't stay like that it's not
clear anymore i actually thought it was
a good movie
you know the problem with it is la la
land was like
a musical and it had some
cool jazz moments because you know
jasmine
they don't like musicals because people
think oh the musical music that's jazz
and it's like yeah it's kind of like
broadway
poppy kind of stuff it's not it's not
jets so i think
there was mixed messages and that people
were just kind of putting it all
together
in one so i think la la land got some
hate because of that but in reality
if you just look at him in a real way
the jazz stuff was good
i like the intent of the movie i like
what ryan's saying here he has his own
opinion about the music and he's just
trying to fight for it and
keep it here and it brought a lot of
attention to the jazz world honestly
next up whiplash
that's not a normal thing just walk on
stage you're not supposed to be the
drummer for that particular song
i think he got kicked off of the concert
or something like that
and he didn't even wait for the director
to count it off normally in the big bang
situation the director has to go
one two one two ready
and blah so everybody knows where they
are
miles totally skipped that part you
would definitely make any band director
angry at that point when you're in a
school you're going off of what the
band director tells you to do he's
counting everybody in he's bringing the
drums
he's bringing in the bass he's bringing
in orchestra so
you're trained to just do that most of
these kids haven't been in a jazz club
they don't have a bunch of years under
their belt
to kind of know how things flow so you
could tell everybody's kind of startled
like what's happening
that kind of thing happens when you have
a smaller group and you're in a club at
jazz club and you're playing then you
can be like yo all right come in here
and everybody's kind of vibing but when
you have a big band and it's an
educational
kind of surrounding even that doesn't
happen at all because everybody's
waiting on the director to come in on
their part
so it can definitely be a trainwreck for
jazz big band is like
um you have a rhythm section which is
like piano
guitar bass and drums maybe some some
percussion and that means you have like
five or six saxophones in a row four or
five trumpet players
behind them you got like 15 20 horns
bigger the band is
then the word orchestra starts coming
into play a lot of times
orchestra means they're strings but some
people kind of use
the words together it could be they say
they may say
so-and-so's jazz orchestra but it's
really a big band
the good thing about this is miles
teller is actually playing the drums you
can see he's playing the drums
the drums is the one instrument that
everybody knows what it looks like to
play drums
so for the most part you can tell if
somebody's faking the drums or not
for the most part most people don't know
what it a saxophone fingering is or the
trumpet player's fingering and that beat
is not an easy beat to play he's playing
a few different
rhythms all over the set
some cross rhythms happening one rhythm
going into another rhythm hi-hat's doing
one thing
he's playing around it go ahead miles
this particular song is called caravan
it's a duke ellington
uh composition very very very famous
duke ellison composition
he was a very famous band director very
famous composer
and this is one of the songs that
musicians love to play
it's one of the songs that doesn't do
the natural what everybody does when
jazz they swing ding ding ding ticketing
ticketing
this has more of a or four bass drum
like
kind of having like a more middle
eastern kind of vibe
you know and more rhythmic than normal
so
the beginning of the song is more that
vibrant in the middle of the song
it goes right to swing
people love to play this song because
it's very easy to
kind of do arrangements of this song
because it's not necessarily
locked so hardcore into the traditional
jazz
pattern of swing this is really a
drummer which is why it makes sense they
put it in whiplash because drummers love
switching from this to that and then
setting up going back and setting up
going there
a lot of the song really depends on the
drummer's direction
i know some of these musicians in there
so that's one reason why i definitely
know these are the cats playing
the actual song you know so the actual
thing is great the trump player that
comes in
they're kind of having a conversation if
you will
and the drums is really holding the
conversation together
very very very interesting how that's
happening and that's that's really what
happens in real life
and myles is holding his own playing it
i like the fact that they're giving so
much shine to
the drums it's not so common that
drummers take the leads there's been
drummers that have had their own bands
that take leads
on a lot of things and it's an
interesting way to look at it where they
hear it it takes on a different
a different direction but it's it's dope
because the drums the drum set
in any band really is probably the most
important piece
it's the heartbeat so in a real way this
movie definitely
allows you to see how important you know
the drums are
in the band i went to a high school for
performing arts in houston texas for
jazz
you know the drummers didn't have to
play to their finger split that's not
the actual thing
but our jazz director he was hard on us
he was heartless in a good way
that's why so many great musicians come
out of my school because of
how hard our director was on us there's
a big band you know
every everything has to be tight so even
in my high school when we used to do big
bands
we had sectionals which means after
school your section would have a
rehearsal with the jazz director
just your section to make sure all of
our things were on point everything we
hit
all the notes were on point and tight
and then we come together
because everything has to be perfect
precise because if you miss a note if
you go early or you go late you miss a
note
it's going to be heard because
everything's so tight and everybody has
their own
place to play directors can definitely
hear all the mistakes because they know
the music
they probably perform the same chart for
years with other bands
that particular director might have did
this for 10 years already so by the time
you get here
the director knows it by heart so any
little bitty thing that's off he knows
he's ready for it he's ready you know so
yeah
he's got to be on point next up miles
ahead
no bias or anything but i did score this
movie
so did i win a grammy for the soundtrack
of the movie
yes but none of that has any bearing on
what i'm saying about the movie
you pick up that note in the solo
passage we could add that to it
because and then have them double it
when the section plays
you want me to make a note here yeah we
just try it
this is the movie by don chito i gotta
say he did a great job
with mazda's voice and his vibe even the
lingo he was saying
glycendos and the way he was describing
what he wanted with the big band was
very realistic at on point a lot of
people don't know he
actually is a musician as well so he
knows musical terms he understands it
and all that stuff
that really made it easy to work with
him
that's in the forte see yeah we're
coming in right
that's right and i wanted to sting it
you know hit it yeah and really take it
off then they gotta do
this miles davis in this scene he's
talking to gil
evans who is an amazing arranger it was
a big deal that
they were doing an album together but
yeah some of the lingo he's talking
about here
you know he says i wanted to sting i
want to sting right here
it's kind of like an exclamation point
for horns
you know accentuate it and you play it
loud you played a certain way so
that they call that stinging or a
glissando he says somebody called sando
that's when you kind of do a little
glitch going into a note a lot of
people's like
[Music]
you know that that's kind of what you do
in that situation
yeah and when they take it off then they
gotta jiggle this sandal
in jazz it is common to work with the
producer it depends the producer can
mean certain things to certain people
some producers don't have anything to do
with the music
at all most jazz musicians produce their
own record as far as the music
goes they're kind of taking care of the
music part most of them
you have some producers who come in as a
producer who are doing other things
but they're not necessarily touching the
music but they're making sure that
everything is running smoothly
studio time the musicians are there
people are getting paid
all the eyes are dotted and the t's are
crossed
and hold that over the next next
measurement hold that over the
measurement and then better result
then i grew yeah we should get them back
in let's do it
thanks man that little cord that don
cheeto hit right there
that was me they filmed it beforehand
but i just made the cord cool
made it something that would probably be
you know
something that you probably hear in this
particular setting i had to do a lot of
that in this movie
where the scene was shot already and the
musicians were playing already
and i had to come in with myself and
another bass player and another drummer
and look at what they're doing and make
it sound good
but make it look like they're actually
playing so
that was a difficult thing to do versus
somebody hearing what i've already done
and they have to mimic me
but make it sound good be musical about
this [ __ ]
be wrong strong okay otherwise
miles davis is known for his attitude
with the trumpet and without the trumpet
but he always said
it's not the note that counts it's the
person
that's playing the note that counts one
person can play a c
and then the other person can play a c
and it sounds like two
totally different notes it's about the
confidence behind the note
and all these things behind the note
basically play it with confidence or
don't play what's also good about this
is all of don's fingerings are correct
on the trumpet he actually learned how
to play trumpeting this part
it's really cool that he did that the
trumpet is very important in jazz the
role of it is very important i think it
comes
it probably stems from louis armstrong i
would imagine why it's such a
thing because louis armstrong was the
father of jazz and you know
he was so famous and he sang and he was
like he was like a pop star
but a jazz musician the two instruments
that really symbolize jazz a lot of
times is the trumpet and the saxophone
because charlie parker's the saxophone
because of the trumpet
it's louis armstrong and then after that
you have miles davis
who made the trumpet super cool he made
being a jazz position
cool he was like miles davis was like a
rock and roll star
but in jazz gil evans had a specific way
of arranging things he just had a sound
that
no one else really had how he stacked
certain horns against each other when
you arrange
it's up to you how you want to stack
things against each other where you want
to put the sacks
where do you want to put the trumpet how
do they blend all that kind of stuff
matters
the levine's had just a smooth cool
laid-back sound we got miles davis who's
already cool in his
way and who he is and then you have gil
evans that has this
cool sound it was a whole package deal
and they called it birth of the cool
this was in like the 50s like late 50s i
believe somewhere in there
and this particular way of recording was
the way they recorded everybody in the
same room
you didn't have a lot of separation
booths to separate the sounds so that's
another reason why you got to be tight
and rehearsal was
a thing because if one person messed up
you had to do the whole thing over again
unlike now
you can have different people in
different rooms and kind of you know
overdub people and do all these things
to make recording what it is but
here everybody's in the rooms everything
kind of has to be hit
and quit perfect miles was more than
just a jazz musician miles was
an attitude miles was uh
so influential and he represented change
he represented no ceilings you just
always want to move and and try to go on
to the next thing for me and for a lot
of my musician friends for
the music the genre all genres really
you know he was the first person to
really just say
forget what the norm is forget what the
rules are
and just totally break the rules and
repeatedly keep breaking the rules
rest in peace miles davis next up
anchorman
the legend of wrong burgundy we will be
honored if you will play jazz flute for
us
i can't please you play jazz flute
i dabble going to see a show and getting
called up to play
is actually normal in jazz for sure i go
there
see people play all the time you know
and somebody might see me and be like oh
rob you want to play so
if there's musicians on stage and they
know one of the musician friends in the
audience a lot of times they'll call
them up so
when you have a flute and you know that
that instrument is kind of small so you
can tuck it away
versus if you have a saxophone or you
play guitar or something like that then
it's like okay it's harder to
just jump on and play with someone for
me if i get caught up it depends
it depends on the band the band's not
good
i mean but if the band's good
yeah i'll jump on it all depends on the
vibe and you know what's happening
guys east harlem shakedown e flat that's
not an actual tune but i love the name
of it
east harlem shakedown that's amazing he
called the key
so it's not only calling a song that
doesn't exist at all
but i'm gonna tell you what keep e-flat
it's not an e-flat that's the greatest
thing
normally musicians know the keys because
most songs are in the keys
musicians played in most songs are in
one key like you know this song
musicians played in this key the key
thing really comes into play when
there's a singer
there's a vocalist then the vocalist
comes up and says
let's play this song but i sing it in
this key because every vocalist sings in
different keys nobody comes up and says
i only play this song in this key when
it's the instrument but
for vocals you have to change keys a lot
of times
keep the simple splashy and uh jerry
let's take the baseline for a walk
keep the symbol splashy it's not an
actual
lingo that real jab musicians say they
do say
you know walk base so take the baits for
a walk
they don't necessarily say it like that
but they'd be like yo walk the base here
taking the base for a walk means walking
the base which means
making the base uh play quarter notes or
eighth notes but basically continuous
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom not
like boom
boom boom no real space in between it's
just continuously
kind of like when you're walking down
the street
[Applause]
[Music]
there's also the issue of the microphone
he's walking along over there he's now
he's in the bathroom he was
walking through the club the mic is on
the stage
but you can still hear them perfectly
clear
[Music]
song they're playing it's not a first of
all it's not a real song and it's not
even how
a real jazz song would actually go the
sections they're going in is
is something that was purely made for
this score you know me to
accentuate the things that to bring to
light the things that he's doing it's
following that
kind of thing but a real jazz song
wouldn't take on that kind of
characteristic
and do what it's doing these guys
weren't playing these instruments this
was like a total
you know mess they didn't even look like
they were playing what you heard
really obviously that wasn't even the
point there's a part in there where you
can hear
the bongos and the drums play at the
same time
[Music]
the the bongos are by the drums it's
overdone you can hear this actual
drummer an actual bongo player playing
separately
the drinking um liquids with the flute
i'm gonna go ahead and
say that's not a thing i'm gonna go
ahead and say that
for obvious reasons it's not a straw the
lighting your instrument on fire i mean
that's not a thing in jazz anyway people
in the rock world have done it but
not so much for a jazz flute settings i
think they did a good job
with this movie and over doing some of
the things making fun of the genre in a
way
even when it's a jab performance that's
interesting it's not like this
i wish they weren't next up mobetta
blues
that's terence blanchard on trumpet
uh kenny kirkland and jeff tayne watts
some of my favorite musicians in general
on this soundtrack you have denzel here
who's you know cleaning his horn putting
it together
which is the thing that trembler players
have to do a lot anybody
he's taking care of his instrument in
the real way so that's what he has to do
and denzel really learned how to do that
on his own and he did a lot on his own i
actually talked to terence blanchard
about this movie
he was telling me how he really learned
the fingerings to everything
so it looks real and learned how to put
the trumpet take it apart
and put it back together you know on his
own after a while
and learn how to clean it for real
the beginning of that song when it first
came on and they were showing the john
coltrane poster and everything
you heard the rhythm section but you
also heard the orchestra behind it so
that was strings
also added to that which is really cool
spike lee also has a lot of strings in
the music and his films in general
his dad billy is a string arranger
and so he orchestrated a lot of the
strings in this movie
before this movie he did all of the
string arrangements for the spike movies
that's kind of a
thing for spikey movies when you hear
the music
you hear a certain sound strings and
that sound
[Music]
that's a total real thing absolutely
people do that all the time i do that
even if it's not thinking i'm in a band
i do it just i kind of just noodle and i
do my hands like this and i kind of just
noodle and kind of practice in my head
but i definitely know we can look weird
for sure doing that stuff
that's real sometimes it's not even
about the hitting the notes when you're
seeing them it's just about you're just
playing the notes and
so you really hear it in your head with
denzel he's just kind of hearing the
notes in his head
and kind of like mimicking the notes out
loud but it's not
accurate notes per se it just helps get
the thought out
it could be a rhythmic thought so it's
not even really about the notes it's
about the rhythm
clark what time is it 1 o'clock p.m what
does that mean
that means you're practicing that's
right means i'm practicing
and if you know i'm practicing and you
know i don't finish practicing until two
o'clock
which is for at least another 60 minutes
while you're buzzing my bus
that's also a very real thing a lot of
people have a
a practice schedule every day
practice from i knew a dude that
practiced every day
from one to ten that was a normal thing
for him like you know
a lot of musicians are like that i'm
going to practice i'm practicing and
that's all i'm doing don't bother me
when i'm
practicing i need to practice once you
start touring you start working you got
kids
you have real life things all the time
you have less and less time to practice
sometimes i'll fit in
i'll fit in a 10 minute practice if i
can it's not really about
how long you practice it's about what
you practice really if you can
concentrate on something for 20 minutes
15 minutes 10 minutes just concentrate
on it
sometimes that's better than practicing
10 hours because sometimes people say
they're practicing 10 hours and
they play for 10 hours but they didn't
learn anything it's really about
the concentration how much you put into
the small amount of time you
allot yourself to practice a certain
time to do this
a certain time to do that everything's
on a schedule a timetable
listen up tight ass let me explain
something to you
life is short okay i need it like this
to do all the things i got to do i like
order
order's fine but you're ridiculous
there is no clock out time you don't
clock out when you do music
it's 24 hours it's a part of your life
it's
the love of your life it's hard to fit
another person in there
and a lot of times it doesn't work
sometimes people can find love and it
works out
the balance is perfect that person
understands what your passion is
and they can know how to navigate with
you through that
but a lot of times it doesn't work out
because sometimes you know music is the
other partner
you know music's music's your life
partner so it's like
you gotta compete with that it can be
definitely hard being in a relationship
next up round midnight well it's always
about
music
and
playing the saxophone
first off this is dexter gordon we're
watching here he's
one of the masters of the music tenor
saxophone player very influential
in jazz and this is him really just
talking about real life about how music
in general when you're a musician
and that's really what you do it's not
just a hobby but it's really what you do
there's no breaks from it even when you
sleep you think about music
you're dreaming about some music there's
a constant thing in your life
all the time i bet this particular part
of the movie probably wasn't even
scripted
it's so you know authentic and also
let's not forget uh the other master
teacher mr herbie hancock he
scored this film this this was a
definitely an important movie
my love is music
and it's 24 hours a day
music consumes you because if you're a
composer then a lot of times you're
composing
based off of what you do in your life
you get influenced by
all these different things and you start
writing music based on these things i'm
always
constantly singing melodies in my mind
coming up with melodies or humming them
that come out of the blue
becomes one with your life because
that's what feeds one feeds the other
there's so much you have to know even to
be a bad jazz musician
you got to be kind of good just to play
the music it just requires so much
because
it's a music that you improv and you
come up with things on the spot
every time you play that's really what
the thing about jazz is more than any
other music
i look at my mouthpiece
and it's all bloody but i haven't felt a
thing
for saxophone players of dexter gordon
they're playing with a reed a wooden
reed
and so therefore you can cut your lip
you know i've seen it happen i've had an
injury um because
i'm always having to have my hands in
this position
so i've developed something called
golfer's elbow whatever instrument you
have you can have a certain
over time you know have an injury
because of it like how he just kind of
put it all in one thing like basically
he's saying his
his life is music and his love is music
he loves music so much that it's
a constant part of his life 24 7. and
any real musician
will feel the same i think anybody feels
the same with whatever your passion is
if you're a person that's fortunate
enough to
find your passion and have a passion you
probably think about that passion
all day all the time thanks for watching
the breakdown with me watching these
cool clips these jazz movies
appreciate the hang but i gotta go so
i'm out